- [Instructor] We're told
that Felipe feeds his dog
the same amount every day
from a large bag of dog food.
Two weeks after initially opening the bag,
he decided to start weighing
how much food remained
in the bag on a weekly basis.
Here's some of his data.
So we see after 14 days,
there's 14 kilograms remaining.
Then after another seven days pass by,
so now we're at 21 days
from the beginning,
there's only 10.5 kilograms left.
Then after 28 days there
are seven kilograms left.
All right, so we are going
to try to use this data
to start answering some
interesting questions,
and maybe we'll also try to
visualize it with a graph.
So the first thing that
we might try to tackle
is well how much food was
in the bag to begin with
if we assume that he's using
the same amount of food every week.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
How much food was in the bag to begin with
if we assume that Felipe
is feeding his dog
the same amount every week?
Okay now there's several ways to do this,
but to help us visualize this,
let me see if I can graph
the data that we have
and then see what would happen
as we approach the beginning
of this, of what's going
on here, the dog feeding,
and maybe as we go to the end as well.
So let's see, this is my
x-axis, this is my y-axis.
I'm going to make x-axis
measure the passage of the days,
so number of days on the x-axis.
And on the y-axis I'm going to measure,
I'm gonna measure food remaining,
and that is in kilograms.
And let's see, it looks like
maybe if my scale goes up to,
let's make this five, 10, 15, 20,
and then 25, I can make
it a little higher, 25,
I think this will be sufficient.
And then we wanna go up to 28 days,
and it looks like they're
measuring everything
on a weekly basis, so let's say
that this is seven, 14, 21, and then 28.
And they gave us some data points.
So after 14 days, there's
14 kilograms remaining,
so 14 days, there's 14
kilograms remaining,
right over there.
After 21 days, there's
10.5 kilograms remaining,
21 days, 10.5 is right about there.
After 28 days there's
seven kilograms remaining,
so after 28 days, seven kilograms.
And we're assuming the rate
of the dog food usage is the same,
that he's feeding his dog
the same amount every week.
And so this would describe a line,
that the rate is going to
be the slope of that line,
and then if we can plot this line,
if we know where that line
intersects the x and y-axes,
we might be able to figure
out some other things.
So actually let me draw a line here,
let me see if I can use
this little line tool
to connect the dots in a reasonable way.
So let's say it looks something
like that, that's our line,
that'll describe how quickly
he is using his dog food.
So let me make sure that this dot is,
should be on the line as well.
Now let's try to answer
that first question,
and think about how we might do it.
How much food was in
the bag to begin with?
So what point here
represents how much food
was in the bag to begin with?
Well that's the amount of
food remaining at day zero,
at the beginning of this,
so that would be this
point right over here,
would describe how much food
was in the bag to begin with.
This would be the y-intercept,
y-intercept is when
our x value is equal to
zero, what is our y value.
And when we just look at it, the graph,
it looks like it's a little bit over 20,
but we could find the exact value
by thinking about the slope,
which is thinking about
the rate at which the dog
food is being depleted.
We can see that every week,
every week that goes by,
or every seven days that goes by,
it looks like we use 3.5 kilograms.
Or another way to think about it,
every two weeks it looks like
we use an entire kilogram.
So let me put it this way,
when we go plus 14 days, plus 14 days,
it looks like we use up, or the
food remaining goes does by,
goes down every two weeks it
goes down by seven kilograms,
seven kilograms, negative seven kilograms.
So if we wanna figure
out this exact value,
we just have to reverse things.
If we are going back 14 days,
then we are going to
go up seven kilograms.
So if we were at 14, up seven kilograms,
this right over here is
the point zero comma 21.
So how much food did Felipe
start with in the bag?
21 kilograms, and we got
that from the y-intercept.
Now another question is how much
is Felipe feeding his dog everyday.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well we know every 14 days
he's feeding the dog seven kilograms,
so one way to think about it is,
and we're really looking at the slope here
to figure out the rate at
which he's feeding his dog.
So the slope is equal
to our change in the y,
so negative seven kilograms,
every our change in the x, every 14 days,
and so seven over 14 is
the same thing as 1/2,
so this is equal to negative
1/2 of a kilogram per day.
So this tells us everyday
the food remaining
is going down half a kilogram,
so that means he's feeding his dog,
assuming his dog is eating
the food and finishing it,
that his dog is eating
half a kilogram a day.
And if we wanted to ask another question,
how many days will the bag last?
How would you think about that?
And we know it's going
to be out here someplace,
if we just continue that line,
because this point right over here,
where our line intersects the x-axis,
that would be our x-intercept,
that is the x value when
our y value is zero,
and our y is the amount of food remaining.
So we wanna know what day do
we have no food remaining.
And we could try to estimate it,
or we could figure out it exactly.
We know that every 14 days
we use up seven kilograms.
So if we are at seven, as
we are right over here,
and we go 14 days in the future,
we should use up the
remaining contents of the bag,
so plus 14 days we're going
to use up the remaining seven kilograms.
And so this should happen
14 days after the 28th day,
so this is going to be the 42nd day.